if you roll two fair dice which is more  likely a sum of eleven or a sum of  twelve  leibniz one of the inventors of calculus  incorrectly reasoned the two events were  equally likely because each sum can  happen in one way  six plus six is equal to twelve and six  plus five is equal to eleven  in reality a sum of eleven is twice as  likely as a sum of twelve  when we roll two fair dice there are 36  equally likely outcomes of ordered pairs  the sum of 12 happens once but the sum  of 11 occurs twice  leibniz made the mistake of thinking the  two dice were indistinguishable objects  but lymnus's mistake provides a very  important lesson it's okay to make a  mistake or miss a simple question in  math class  be persistent and keep solving problems  and eventually people will remember you  not for your mistakes but only for your  successes